Starbound is big really big you just
won't believe how vastly hugely
mind-bogglingly big it is and with a
universe at your beck and call where do
you begin
thankfully Starbound starts off by
tethering you to a single world as soon
as you've named your character fashioned
out of the exploratory spirit of
Minecraft and Terraria and I'm sure
you're probably about as tired of
hearing about games like Minecraft and
Terraria as I am
starburns premise is to take you away
from a single procedurally generated
world and into an entire universe of
planets whose earth you can swing your
pickaxe into here's what it's like to
play Starbound this is Greg our video
producer who was playing as one of the
robot dudes the glitch hey Greg Greg is
starting on his ship Greg is warping
down to the planet to begin his voyage
of discard Greg he's being chased by
some kind of weird ear thing Greg has
fallen into a cave Greg's died hey hey
that's ok
at the beginning Starbound is less of an
intergalactic space adventure and more
of a cuddling up to a campfire hoping
you don't freeze to death
simulator a thin progression system that
developer chuckle fish says is temporary
helps you get your bearings tiers of
quests throughout boss monsters and
slowly unlock deeper more dangerous
expanses of this broad universe for you
to explore one day we've promised epic
player-versus-player space wars but
right now Starbound is a game where you
make your own fun there are two main
ways you can play at the moment
exploring and crafting the two go
hand-in-hand
really bits and bobs gained from
rummaging around the cavernous innards
of these planets become the ingredients
for weapons and armor in turn that
equipment allows you to explore more
dangerous terrain for more valuable
items to create even better weapons and
so on and so on if there's one unifying
rule in Starbound
it's that most things want to kill you
worlds are quite small and many of the
game's non-combat mechanics such as
farming as
still underdeveloped this means you're
forced to spend a lot of your time
fighting which is a shame because
fighting isn't all that fun combat is a
routine charge of sword flailing and
bullets and death carries the harsh
penalty of losing sizable chunks of
income forcing you into grinding through
even more foes since fighting is also
one of the main ways to make money but
these annoyances are offset by the
delightful experience of venturing once
more into the unknown the very first
time you spool up your ships engines is
a particularly special moment as you
walk through the galaxy and look to
conquer the first blip on a star map
that you can't help but think you will
one day rule but sometimes things don't
work out as expected my first real
destination in the universe was awful a
molten rock of fissures and furnaces a
lack of preparation was my error and I
became stranded on a limp planet of sad
Grey's and fatal Reds I was quickly
thrown into the air by what looked like
an adorable rabbit thing that turned out
to be evil and have telekinetic powers
and I then landed in the pit of lava and
died horribly I flew to a moon and died
almost immediately because duh there is
no oxygen on a moon and this moon was
also populated by what looked like a
fleet of killer robots I'm not sure how
your firm but most of my Starbound
experience involves dying
I've often starve to death drowned
several times and I fallen foul of
extreme cold twice one time I decided to
see how far down I could dig into the
world ended up landing in a terrifying
demonic sanctum of bones and screams and
then realized you can't walk back up to
your spaceship went underground I ran
out of light sources so I couldn't tell
you what ate me but that's the beauty of
Starbound you come out of it with all
sorts of anecdotes you'll want to share
with people this might be a bare-bones
version of the game to come but boy
check out those bones even now Starbound
is an enticing journey of discovery that
reminds you just how exciting it can be
to stare at a sky full of stars